I guess the I guess the thing to kind of
know about her is I think she she has a
couple things that she can do better
than any other character in the game
it's an example being examples being she
has a lot of good mix of options to be
on that she's also extremely
maneuverable she can get around the
screen very quickly and will kind of
break down you know it's in the options
she has there and she has more options
than the other than I think any other
character in the game
awesome so those control that sort of
real estate pretty well yeah yeah uh
preferred pretty well and you'll know to
notice with her variation that the
glowing tattoos that are on her body is
kind of like the representation of
primal man
yes Pyromancer I think has the doesn't
have any no lose the change to speak
just specials or the other traits she
actually gets a whole lot of difference
but we'll get more of that later
so I guess sure I hope you've been for
this we have to get run
sorry Jim hi her stream he's so yeah so
I guess like kind of the the first thing
we can kind of go over yeah so the to
ground specials that she has are kind of
reminiscent from NJ Ford's from the
previous game she's been so she's got
this drill which hits low on the new
India's area the he expression allows
her to continue the combo from map very
useful and she has her overhead flip oh
yeah
so that one image you can say we
couldn't come up with an adult oh so
that allows her to basically mix up
often in accomplishing so basically any
chain you're doing you can Princeton
when they're walking or you can throw
out something you can't keep them on
their toes isn't anything can happen and
their peoples come out pretty quick
since ladder drill has made it back
because I did need a couple of tweezers
to learn the product on it when you give
us a drill yeah we tried to give her you
know a lot of homages to kind of old
school in case stuff she's had in the
past so and she's got the air drill
right yes so so that what you're talking
about she has this kind of broad set of
air boost kind of has air high and low
options which not a lot of cares we
really have a demand of that so she can
do this Hairston with drop which allows
you to hit low from the air I actually
looked at thank you that was nothing for
me
and I didn't know why yeah I mean I'm
still feeling it I believe it and I
don't have those teams anyway oh they
rip right defense I'm sorry
so yeah she's got she got kind of an air
overhead and little option so again much
like I heard around the neighbors kind
of keeping us move up even if it was
used to be just on top of that she also
has this teleport it's kind of her name
in this game the teleport puts her in an
air steam what she's done and she's
actually consumed any of her air moves
that she has that's not just her so she
can do the drills coming out yeah she
could do jerusalem's yeah you can do the
splits on top of that I also do her hair
so if you hold down when you come out of
that you can actually do like yeah for
air neutral which electric pop-up or her
air kick which other
she can also do her hair kind of
horizontal jumping so that allows you to
continue combos and yeah so yeah when
she's in the air and she can actually do
the teleport in midair as well so she
can teleport into a telephone she cannot
teleport yes and no oh yes so if she's
celebrating from the ground normally she
can't do another teleport until she
lands do bdx teleport which is the
important person actually gets blown up
you can do more you can do kind of seeds
house horns and all sorts of crazy stuff
going to do the back one that afford one
of the air anywhere in the screen almost
instantly you know you really have to
watch her and so what's special to this
variation we got so Pyromancer is
probably the closest to kind of her old
set of moves from classic and kay where
she has her fart of all her hair so the
fireball is kind of a different than
this one they kind of have like the
johnnycakes not a mark but she also can
do that in the air so she had duncan yes
these guys hitman you can duck if you
were closer and like that going tend to
fly kind of high so if it's ducking
based on that decision I'm like some of
the other fireballs which so pretty
effective they're high-low versions good
for anything someone out of the air and
you can cancel from you know air
specials and stuff for extending combos
and going back from there teleports
right yeah it's huge number of options
there and then when you out from the air
as well
yes and the arc of those fireballs in
midair kind of covers some interesting
screen space
so actually that we're dealing with a
character that you know look all the
character you fought up till now you're
gonna be dealing with a lot of different
sort of action from the air exactly it's
just more like the angle of attack
Tuesday when you've seen exactly very
good we want to make sure you know she
had this kind of different feeling it
kind of stood out you know as this try
out so yeah there he expired well
they're very fast it kind of abuses her
kind of old school in Cape Horn fire
ball animation and there's that flavor
and then the other move she has in this
trade with brand new move Nicole Pegasus
was try to start necessary yes
dark dust so she throws this handful of
mystical dusts and puts this guy in this
dusted state and so when the guys
covered in dust if you take her if you
hit the employment with a fireball and
fireball the significantly more damage
yes like not as much yeah it's I think
it's a consistent like ten damage right
now on top of that so that applies he
expired all the toys for aircar Bowl and
she actually has this normal stream that
ends and kind of a fireball as well so
if you can get into the ground through
combo to right yeah exactly so you can
kind of Lynn yeah you can kick the combo
into this route and I think it even in
some circumstances you may be able combo
from the shroud well I bring weights are
kind of like you know huge incentive to
go in and you can either back away and
throw a fireball so that Fargo does chip
damage significantly more chip damage of
some of the blocks and so you
like incentivize some to dodge their
projectiles when they're not let's get
on to the next one I think we're gonna
try her for let's see it's how huge its
it kobu jutsu yeah and don't worry we're
just we're doing these in crazy mode
right now we will be showing some intros
do something after the next one so yeah
so this one she gains her tonfas which
give her a lognormal tax and a couple
new special move so I think this one is
probably here mostly interested in your
face treat for Tom yet she gets like
Romeo's Watchers she gets a faster I
think her fastest standing normal which
is real I connect to this couples been
there they goes into an overhead starts
faster than the curve normally you know
and then she also gains entire map
damaging on the ground and how do I deal
with her like kind of one two three
combo sequestered yeah so that one's
interesting because you container you
can see Vee X gets the first hit and the
last seven okay yeah so you can you can
spend two bars here you know really
spilling you know just a hole in three
pocket but it allows you to either like
it are getting Rican
yeah I showed that just did you mostly
capture that no no no the suits don't
fit me okay and then she's got the the
diet as well yes so she needs to do air
mu which is this kind of thoughtful
Tompa died from midair which allows her
like if something is across the street
from you it looks let's say you go all
the way to the far to the screen almost
thrown her projectiles okay like jump
teleport hasn't died completely across
the screen that's so close this is
really fast you know more more
aggressive options washing your face
yeah how much you've done and then she
also has a projectile in this video yeah
that's exactly career Tompa throw which
if you do the X version another kind of
will throw back to and don't show it all
Kyle G to combo interesting combo
options with her and is there anything
that we miss with this one I think I
think so yeah so she has even more air
moves now yes in this as well yeah I
think we eat she beat straight games new
air moves as well as new ground awesome
alright cool so what's up
well the character select main menu you
and me kind of let's do this
I think we're gonna jump into her as a
dragon knight would know got nada
meghanadha yeah this this one has kind
of been improving pretty monocular
around the office people seem to really
like this less variation thing I haven't
read in five years probably katana yeah
yeah I mean as the seconds tick away
when we can talk so you'll notice she's
got the the staff on her back that's
that's the visual the Gator the
indicator
you're not gonna happen yes mark she
uses but it's fun to say
princess still alive deceiver no way to
speak to a loyal subject
those chanting eyes yeah that's good I
really like to get sure we can do with
the they're not gonna yeah yeah it had a
lot of interesting things you can do
with this for one you have like some of
these I think we pretty sure this the
longest normal in the game included for
back to she gains in this or you can
poke something from the almost across
the entire screen pretty penny and then
she could again she gains some extra
combos gain some like that that one
actually in particular as one of my
favorites cuz actually creates another
penalty you can do the kick version off
of that which he is universally so
that's to to Enders off of that low high
keep the guy guessing so it definitely
adds additional moves to her normal
fight style exactly that she wouldn't
normally have and then she's got the
kind of like sweet kick yeah cuz I'd
better swing kick I'll and then exp can
yes like I can't get any live so you're
just gonna happen
yeah damn so the extreme speed kicked as
well as a move you can do from the air
allow you to give it to this alternate
spins in this stance try calling staff
stance it's a lot like has a whole bunch
of options there we go yeah so that's
that stance get an overhead option you
have a low option yeah I love you stamps
on ya the stamp the stamp move is fun
and that's the know when you do right
from there yep swing it actually puts
you back into the like colmillo stand
yeah so you can go in from the ground
and extend your combo that way you can
go to the air and one thing that's
interesting is you know we kind of have
that rule you can't do multiple
teleports in the air well unless you
land
well the snaps dance actually counts as
away from the so if you can actually
teleport into a staff stance to be jump
in and out of it all sorts of crazy
options you can actually like kind of
like a period of time without touching
your brownies in traditional shoes or
your just Pogo around how about we see
two people J can do it the others around
oh my gosh Spencer all the way around
there all around and then the top falls
off that's good
that's insults that's good that's good
salt giveth me again what's this you're
gonna playing against that yep all right
good let's go
maybe you could do a fatality but I'm
going to play it has character don't
never back to the staff treat let's half
the cattle three quarters the test
yeah oh you okay no I'm pretty bad at
Johnny Cage so let's look let's just
look like there was a character's yeah
[Music]
you can only do in the air
in another kind of reminiscent of her
evening Camaro you've got a second k4o
can actually charge that to you that
fireman he has so little help
she's gonna be in the air a lot so you
have to hit her you know which is in
here oh here we go
slides right through don't need those
it's gonna hang on this I like in
testing bola is the human slide good
name humor slide how nonchalant she is
with just like oh that's an intestine